you know while while this is going on
and you're going to COA where where's
your family well they they got sent to
go ahead yeah my family got here just
like one year like before I just start
my paperwork started I just start moving
from Turkey to C then to Kosovo right
they just got here and they're in where
are they they're they landed in a place
called Fort picket in Virginia which is
like an an army holding uh base um for
ref processing refugees cuz it was such
a fast thing nobody was processed
leaving there so now we've got a little
time we're going to actually process who
these people are and really dig into who
they are um so they sat there for what
two months no for more than three months
three months yeah they were over there
for further processing of the paperworks
of the like medical exam examination
everything like this and
and you your your wife emotionally like
how is she happy to be there yeah in the
first in the first week when they just
evacuated on the aircraft in military it
was the first time for a woman with the
thousands of people like maybe more than
like thousand you know in a one aircraft
they just gathered to each other you
know there was no other privacy to some
men just touch you around your back or
around your hands around your legs lamps
like this so for her it was so difficult
I bet very difficult and also you know
she didn't wash her body her feet for
more than two days from from going
through the SE all the shits all the
dirts from the S canel when she just
crossed that it was just inside at her
body wow yeah and she just like had very
like a bad smell and so when they just
got catch her and after that they just
got to here and fore it when I was
talking with her she had a good feeling
yeah and she was so happy and she didn't
care about anything on the past she was
just thinking for the future especially
for my kids for our kids yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's beautiful and when that
you know was going on it was like these
people R I don't care what you say your
family's coming to live at my house they
don't knowwhere to go yeah yeah uh I'll
be damn if we're going to make it this
far and you get thrown in a dangerous
neighborhood somewhere cuz that's that's
what happens is lot of refugees end up
going to the inner cities of these
places number one where it's dangerous
number two where it's they can't afford
this they've left everything behind they
don't have credit they don't and you're
going to send them to go live in this
other war zone right right so I was like
absolutely not so I I rally my little uh
Town together and you know we collect
donations I mean at the drop of a hat I
got a my wife's friends you know they at
the drop of a hat man they had beds
clothes wow go down the list anything
these people would need I mean it was
like overnight it was appeared in our
house yeah it it was awesome so you had
the family there with you before he got
there yeah yeah and and and what was
that like unbelievable I mean you know
it took forever once they got to Fort
picket uh the the army base for
processing was it was it two months they
were there three months three months
yeah so they just wait and you can
imagine after everything I've been
through I still haven't met these people
we're preparing for them to to get here
I don't have a job this is my job now
until Rah gets here right right and is
your girlfriend now your wife yeah and
and is she excited about yeah this must
have been czy it was interesting to see
CU you know I know Afghans and I've
traveled the world you know she at that
point she hadn't really you know so
she's asking like you know do they speak
English like do I have to wear a hijab
like I'm like
no but it was interesting to see that
that Clash of uh cultures I bet because
it was like her she's uh labor and
delivery nurse so she she meets you know
people who speak different languages you
know to have somebody like that live in
your house oh yeah yeah it was
interesting interesting to see but yeah
we finally got the call from Fort picket
hey uh these people say that they're
going to come live with you are you on
board with that I'm like let's go uh put
them on a plane and they flew him uh
into Knoxville and um my wife me and my
wife were hanging out waiting on them
and then I got a tracking device on the
on the plane you know I know exactly
where they're at and they land like here
they come and then here you know here
they come through through security and
you know it was like they went from
people just that I just saw pictures of
to like I'm now holding my interpreter's
kids wow you know it's
just the most it's so powerful you know
it is so
powerful you know that's the realities
of War you know that's yeah sure you
know military
people they get out and they have issues
and this and that but you know dude this
is those are the ones are the most
affected you know these kids you know
these kids would have never gone to
school especially the two girls they
would have never gone to school you know
they would have just lived under
Darkness like like Rah says yeah um but
to have them show up and man we it was
like I knew them you know and I felt
that you know from them too you know it
was like oh this is that crazy yeah
yeah cuz remember you know in the
beginning of the story his wife's like I
don't know your crazy friend like who is
this dude he's in Tennessee but yeah
when they showed up it was just we
swooped them up and then uh you know we
had been collecting donations and I put
the word out in my little you know
southern town which I also want to point
out and a lot of people have asked me
this you know the South has such a
stigma for being racist and yeah yeah
you know we don't like people that
aren't white redneck right that is such
yeah yeah absolutely and I feel
it necessary to like clear that air for
other people to hear and a lot of times
it's people from that aren't even from
the south that are making this
assumptions you know but we're all poor
down south together you
know and my little town came together
and blew it out of the water you know
these kids showed up but they didn't
have social security numbers yet they
didn't have you know they were missing
so many documents and things
required for them to attend schools
um but you know before those kids showed
up I went to the local school system
where me and my wife went to school you
know just a tiny little town kids that
we went to school with are now teachers
and administrators and so it was cool to
walk in there and like hey guys we don't
have kids because I don't we don't have
kids uh I don't know what this is about
being a you know like a parent here I
don't know what to do but I know I got
three kids inbound here yeah and I don't
know when exactly they're going to be
here but the dad over here wants him
going to school like right away that's
right you know immediately that's right
which is real cool on him yep and so we
lined it up with those administrators
and
um I remember when we got word finally
uh from Fort picket that you know
they're coming to Tennessee everything's
ready the green light let's go you know
the day before they came I went into
that school and I went into this like uh
administrator's office building and it's
all just a bunch you know it's all a
bunch of women and I I walk in there and
I dude I didn't have the words to even
tell them that okay the family's here
like I walked in there and couldn't even
speak you know just cried my eyes out
and they knew what was going on you know
and while I'm sitting there just crying
like a they're like lining up
paperwork in front of me you know these
little oh just sign over here baby yeah
come on now just it's going to be okay
just sign here hey going to be here it's
all right you know and I'm just crying
my eyes out and you know hugged
everybody and thanked them and man Our
Town rallied around these people and I'm
so proud of those people I'm so
unbelievably proud because they moved
faster than people you know I'm talking
to people in the White House when this
is going on I've got contacts everywhere
not that I'm just like some highspeed
dude but you know when you when you do
this work you meet a lot of people and
those women in that that school district
in my town moved 10 times faster than
any government entity could have even
thought to do it was right thing to and
I'm so proud of them for
that that's beautiful yeah so they
showed up we picked him up at the
airport and brought him back to the
house and man I got two little two and a
halfy old twins I got a six-year-old
girl nobody speaks English his wife
speaks a little bit of English uh the
two brothers spoke a little bit of
English and it was just you know because
we're used to living that quiet life you
know we don't have kids we're hanging
out here on the river my biggest concern
is like when am I going to mow like when
is it when is it going to rain because I
got to get out there mowing weed yeah
and it went from
like we got a house full of Afghans here
you know yeah it wild dude but so cool
to you
know they're riding around on my lawn
mower you know with me like they're
loving it they're like yeah let's go so
awesome but it was it was so interesting
to see like the language you know they
didn't speak any English and now they're
full-blown wow can speak all the English
they how long they've been here just two
years years two years two years years
yeah same mon August but that time was
really hard cuz he's still stuck sure in
Turkey sure you know and my bank
account's dwindling it's like I'm not a
rich guy like and I also told him like
Hey I'm I'm not leaving until your
family is in a stable
environment and uh but yeah the
donations just poured in you know
somebody donated there was a great
couple out of Knoxville that donated uh
they they didn't been involved with
refugees in the past and and this this
great woman um uh donated she knew she
wasn't going to be around that much
longer and she donated a a Suburban
older Suburban but it was in great shape
and I mean it was just true Southern
Hospitality coming together to bring
these people in and to make it
happen
[Music]
a